[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre sur
france 3 et sur nos pages facebook pour
la suite de cette édition spéciale de
dimanche en politique en bourgogne
franche comté
aujourd'hui pour le premier anniversaire
de la grande région c'est marie-guite
dufay qui est notre invité bonjour
madame la présidente
alors avant votre hymne interview je
vous propose tout d'abord de l'actualité
obligés de faire un détour par la saône
et loire où un dramatique accident de
car a provoqué la mort de quatre
personnes ce matin à charolles sur la
route centre europe atlantique on
dénombre également 27 blessés ont
rejoint tout de suite en direct sur
place olivia ville amis bonjour olivia
est ce qu'on en sait un petit peu plus
sur les circonstances de cet accident
oui ce qu'on sait c'est que ce but c'est
bien transportait 32 voyageurs des
ressortissants portugais
le bus a quitté la route vers 4h ce
matin il a effectué plusieurs tonneaux
avant de se retrouver dans le fossé
derrière la glissière de sécurité
bilan provisoire donc quatre morts trois
blessés graves et un mieux et bien un
bébé qui a été transporté immédiatement
à l'hôpital le plus proche
les causes de l'accident restent à
déterminer mais on pense que le verglas
a joué un rôle très important
elle est au chauffeur du bus qui sont
sortis indemnes de l'accident vont être
interrogés dans les prochaines heures un
accident qui a eu lieu je le rappelle
est bien sur la rcea une route qui est
réputé pour sa dangerosité
une route qui avait pourtant été
préalablement salé la rcea qui va et
bien dans quelques minutes
rouvrir à la circulation et il faudra
redoubler de vigilance puisque comme
vous le voyez est bien la neige a repris
merci olivia bien sûr on reviendra sur
cet accident dans nos éditions
régionales à midi marie du fait une
réaction cette route reste extrêmement
dangereuse malgré les investissements du
conseil régional et de l'état
je pense déjà aux familles qui sont
vraiment très très éprouvés je pense
aussi aux secours qui sont énormément
mobilisés cette nuit
cet axe routier qui est très insécures
effectivement fait l'objet de toute
l'attention de l'état de la région et
des collectivités nous sommes sur un
programme d'aménagement de deux fois
deux voies de 500 millions d'euros 1 et
pour lesquels vraiment nous faisons le
maximum j'avais même proposé à l'état
une avance de la région pour qu'on
accélère les choses mais l'état a été au
rendez vous donc cet axe fait l'objet de
toute notre attention
même si là je vois que c'est quand même
les conditions de météo qui semble à
l'origine mais c'est un acte très très
insécures nous savons et les travaux
sont engagés et nous ferons tout pour
les accélérer même si ce terme
d'accélération est impropre tentant on
attend on attend depuis si longtemps il
ya beaucoup d'attentes effectivement
alors non à la politique vous avez vu le
reportage de 4e série sur le déroulement
de votre première année de mandat vous
compterez nous reviendrons ensemble sur
les principales étapes de cette année
passée sur l'avenir aussi et puis les
téléspectateurs les internautes vous
interrogions directement
grâce à vous sophie courageot mairie qui
on va jouer tout au long de cette
addition l'interactivité avec vous qui
êtes derrière votre petit écran
vous pouvez commencer à l'émission sur
twitter avec le hashtag diez dit mme
paul bfc comme bourgogne franche comté
et puis cette émission est également
retransmise en direct sur nos pages
facebook de france 3 bourgogne et
franche comté
là aussi vous pouvez vous pouvez déposer
vos questions dans les commentaires et
nous les poserons à manier du fait alors
tout d'abord marie-guite dufay quelques
mots sur le reportage de catherine m
syrie est ce que vous l'avez trouvé
fidèle à ce que vous avez vécu pendant
un an
oui je les trouvais intéressant très
intéressant avec des reportages
notamment sur sur l'économie sur
l'agriculture sur les transports qui
sont très percutant et qui reflète bien
les problématiques les enjeux j'aurais
probablement insisté sur d'autres choses
vous avez eu un prisme très liés au
fonctionnement de l'assemblée et aux
difficultés qui a pu y avoir dans cette
assemblée
nous sommes le plus présent c'est vrai
voilà oui tout à fait je le comprend 1
cela fait partie fait partie du jeu moi
j'aurais davantage insisté sur les
mesures que nous avons prises au niveau
de l'emploi pour booster l'emploi pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait le maximum de
demandeurs d'emploi qui soient formées
pour monter une nouvelle filière dans
notre région par exemple autour de
l'hydrolienne pas sur des mesures
concrètes
mais c'est un reportage qui a vraiment
le mérite de poser les enjeux pour les
téléspectateurs
alors on vous entend dire au début du
reportage vous dit à vos équipes il faut
rester cool alors pourtant l'année elle
n'a pas été très simple pour vous entre
votre opposition qui ne vous fait pas de
cadeau la nouvelle collectivité la
réorganisation vous n'avez jamais craqué
vraiment vous êtes toujours resté cool
alors je sais pas si cool et le terme
mais je suis profondément habité par les
les convictions j'ai envie de faire le
maximum pour sept territoires je crois
en un grand avenir pour la bourgogne
franche comté et j'ai envie de mobiliser
toutes nos forces et je vois que j'ai
une équipe qui est sensationnel j'ai une
équipe d'élus qui on veut une majorité
qui peut sembler courte et qui est en
fait extrêmement solide
donc s'il compte oui mais qui est solide
c'est sale
portant est allé solide parce que nous
débattons et ce qui est important c'est
véritablement que nous nous fixions le
cap et que nous mettions en oeuvre ce
que nous avons décidé de faire sur des
trois grandes priorités et c'est cela
qui compte c'est l'emploi c'est
l'environnement et c'est l'un fraternité
une région fraternelle c'est très
important
alors si l'on en croit les syndicats des
agents du conseil régional a les agents
l'horizon avec une année très très cool
pour reprendre l'expression la cfdt la
cgt et fo ont signé un préavis de grève
pour jeudi prochain le 12 janvier date
de la prochaine session
ils sont exaspérés distille alors
comment se fait-il que il en soit encore
attendre de savoir ce qu'ils vont
devenir un an après la mise en place de
cette région tout simplement parce que
j'ai choisi la méthode du dialogue et
non la mesure autoritaire qui consiste à
asséner les choses laissez lui le
dialogue
oui l'opposition me dis que nos
positions me dis que c'est long et les
représentants des salariés me disent que
je suis brutale donc il faudrait trouver
quand même l'equilibre moi je me suis
engagé sur le fait de ne pas imposer de
mobilité géographique c'est à dire de ne
pas imposer aux agents qui travaillent à
besançon d'aller à dijon et vice versa
premièrement la loi fait que les
salaires ne bougeront pas et je m'engage
au niveau des indemnités à ce
qu'effectivement il n'ya pas non plus de
baisse pour ceux pour les régimes
indemnitaires
nous abordons une phase de négociation
compliquée qui va devoir se dérouler
toute cette année sur justement
l'harmonisation des régimes
indemnitaires qui n'étaient pas les
mêmes
l'harmonisation des temps de travail qui
n'étaient pas les mêmes l'harmonisation
des avantages sociaux
donc il y à une sorte de de pression et
d'affirmation avant cette négociation
mais je le redis les engagements que
j'ai pris seront tenus pas de mobilité
imposée
et puis leur régime indemnitaire qui
restera où il n'y aura pas de baisse de
salaire et de donc de baisse de pouvoir
d'achat pour les uns et les autres
marie-guite dufay en à une question d'un
internaute jean-pierre il se demande
s'il n'y aurait pas une différence entre
vos déclarations et les actes que vous
avez posé ces derniers temps et bien
pour moi il n'y en a aucune puisque je
répète les engagements
épris il n'y a pas de mobilité
géographique imposée pour les agents la
loi fait qu'il n'y aura pas de problème
de salaire bien entendu et au niveau des
indemnités je les dis il n'y aura pas de
baisse des indemnités pour les uns et
les autres à la faveur de cette fusion
ce qui est compréhensible de la part des
questionnements des agents c'est
qu'effectivement comme on a pris du
temps
tout le monde en mai aujourd'hui n'est
pas encore complètement précis et sur
sur l'affectation dont il va faire
l'objet 1 et donc nous avons commencé à
faire les affectations des directeurs
généraux adjoints
ensuite des directeurs des services des
chefs de service et puis maintenant
effectivement c'est l'ensemble des
agents et partir du moment où vous aviez
deux organigramme qu'elle n'a plus qu'un
ya forcément des changements
les choses ne peuvent pas rester
statique et le changement
il fait toujours peur il inquiète donc
moi je comprends parfaitement et c'est
par rapport à ces inquiétudes que j'ai
choisi la méthode du dialogue et le
dialogue il prend du temps donc non il
n'y a aucune différence entre ce que
j'ai annoncé et ce qui se met en oeuvre
ça veut pas dire que je ne comprends pas
les inquiétudes des agents vous pensez
encore pouvoir éviter la gagne vous
allez rencontrer l'aller je ne sais pas
ce qui est important c'est que il est le
sentiment que le dialogue est maintenu
dont je rencontrerai effectivement les
représentants des organisations
syndicales avant l'assemblée budgétaire
c'est tout à fait normal sais pas si ce
sera de nature à enlever le préavis
peut-être que non mais vous savez on est
dans une période de tension qui me
semble normal j'entends les inquiétudes
je redirai bien ce qui m'anime
et quand ce qui m'anime c'est vraiment
le dialogue et le souci du respect des
uns et des autres des compétences des
agents puisqu'on leur demande de se
positionner sur des postes en fonction
de leurs souhaits de leurs compétences
et qu'on a juste les choses par le
dialogue
il me semble qu'on devrait finir par
gommer les inquiétudes vous avez entendu
on l'a vu notamment également dans le
reportage les syndicats ont dit nous
dira alors que même dans la presse
bisontine y en a qui dit c'est le bordel
l'autre qui dit ben voilà les élus se
sont augmenté très rapidement de 20% ils
ont très rapidement augmenter le prix de
la carte grise en franche comté alors
pourquoi nous on attend toujours
mais si j'avais été très vite je pense
que j'aurais eu des réactions encore
plus raide
parce que je vois dans d'autres régions
ça se passe autrement je pense qu'on est
la région qui effectivement peut-être
prend les plus grands moyens du dialogue
et le dialogue c'est le temps donc je la
subis du fait d'un internaute qui nous
envoie une question sous le pseudo le
mécontent il se demande où sont les
économies promises avec la fusion on a
augmenté la carte grise on augmentait
les élus ont fait des réunions des deux
côtés on bouge on circule est ce qu'il
ya vraiment des économies aujourd'hui
les économies elles sont en train
d'arriver sur le plan des charges de
fonctionnement de la région sur les
dépenses de gaz d'assurance de logiciels
puisqu'on a des choses communes et on a
des économies qui se met en place au
niveau des chiffres abonnés jambes oui
aujourd'hui on a deux millions
d'économies sur des charges de
fonctionnement administratif à partir du
moment où on a une contraction de 20 une
mutualisation de nos moyens sur les
achats d'assurance les achats de gaz et
d'électricité sur des logiciels en
matière de notamment d'informatique bon
j'ai toujours dit que le but vers les
gens je les ai toujours dit je l' ai
toujours assumé que le but c'était
vraiment de booster notre économie parce
que derrière notre économie c'est le
développement des emplois et c'est ça
dont on a besoin et que le but de cette
région c'était de sortir de la petite
taille de chacune des régions et de fer
avec la fusion de deux de nos points
forts de nos compétences en matière
industrielle en matière agricole en
matière de recherche de faire de cette
région une région qui booste l'emploi
c'est ça pour moi c'est le développement
économique
c'est ça qui est prioritaire on va en
parler alors en prévision de cette
émission nous sommes les allées
demander leur avis aux habitants de
bourgogne franche comté nous sommes
précisément aller dans les rues de
besançon et de dijon pour leur poser
trois questions la voici la première
elle vous concerne personnellement marié
du fait
connaissez-vous marie-guite dufay oui la
présidente du conseil régional c'est
qu'on n'est pas non je connais pas je ne
connais pas mais pas du tout je pense
que ça va être une femme en politique en
bourgogne franche comté non
connaissez-vous mari plutôt du fail
que pensez vous d'elle je n'ai pas et où
le désolé les gars vraiment oui c'est la
présidente de vision
la présidente de la région
confrontés et pensez vous d'elle
elle paraît pleine de bon sens donc je
pense que ça devrait bien passer avec
elle moi je trouve c'est une présidente
extraordinaire qui a de l'ecoute que
pensez-vous des alors ça n'a pas
vraiment valeur de sondage bien sûr mais
est ce que ça vous surprend qu'on vous
connaissent eux aussi peu dans les rues
de besançon de dijon vous écoutez je
pense que je suis effectivement plus
connu dans les rues de besançon que dans
celle de dijon encore plus connus en
franche-comté qu'en bourgogne c'est pour
ça que je passe beaucoup de temps en
bourgogne ce qui est d'ailleurs très
agréable parce que ça me permet de
découvrir des territoires et au fur et à
mesure de cette découverte de voir
toutes les complémentarités entre
bourgogne et franche comté
il est normal il faut du temps est ce
que ça ne traduit pas aussi une
méconnaissance de l'institution concerne
final de la part des habitants
probablement on le dit toujours
réfléchissez c'est compliqué
d'appréhender une région avec des
compétences qui sont beaucoup plus de
l'ordre stratégique de l'ordre de la
proximité donc ça a toujours été
compliqué de faire connaître et les
compétences de la région à quoi ça sert
la région c'est vrai c'est pour cela
qu'avec mon équipe nous multiplions
détendent échanges avec les habitants et
cafés débats qui sont fustigés par
certains pour moi c'est vraiment la
façon d'aller à la rencontre des gens
puis de leur dire voilà on vient de
tenir une assemblée voilà ce dont on a
discuté
voilà les enjeux du moment et on vient
en discuter avec vous allez nous
retournons dans les rues à besançon et à
dijon pour une question sur le fond
cette fois ci un sur l'importance de
l'action menée par le conseil régional
et ses priorités elle parlait de la
région sont ses principales compétences
économe
des transports les lycées ces questions
s'il à l'économie peut-être qu'on essaye
de développer un peu plus
l'apprentissage et ces choses là pour
que les jeunes puissent trouver du
travail
j'attends surtout au niveau social au
niveau de l'emploi pour les jeunes parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment difficile
de trouver du boulot après cinq six ans
d'études le nord franche-comté continua
à développer l'automobile et tout ça que
le oud ou redevienne quand même le pays
horloger par ference qui nous laisse un
peu nos impôts si c'était possible
saoul comme un séducteur 15 août est
dépassé par un système de bus et
légèrement plus long et beaucoup moins
cher
d'autant ses conséquences forcément en
tant qu'étudiant on aimerait bien que
les transports sont pas trop pas trop
cher pour ce que j'ai ici son corps mois
s'est rénové
on sent bien mais c'est encore pas ça et
puis je pense que la région pourrait
s'améliorer là dedans
moi je vais quitter cette année dont
j'ai longtemps plus grand chose soit
faut quand même qu'à l'investissement
parce que c'est quand même assez
important surtout qu'après notre
orientation c'est vraiment notre avenir
alors investir dans les lycées
marie-guite dufay là il n'y a pas de
remise en cause
c'est une priorité c'est une priorité et
nous avons un engagement de 100 millions
d'euros par an pour moderniser les
lycées pour les numériser pour les
rendre accessibles pour favoriser aussi
ce qu'on appelle la transition
énergétique dans ces lycées et faire en
sorte que à la faveur de travaux
d'efficacité thermique qui ne soient
plus les passoires qu'ils sont ce qui
permettra aussi de réduire leurs charges
nous avons un engagement une ambition là
très très forte et qui se double d'une
ambition d'être aux côtés des familles
en termes de pouvoir d'achat
gratuité des manuels scolaires maintenu
et nous allons aller vers des
tarification sociale progressive pour
les cantines et les internats alors plus
globalement on voit l'importance 5 revel
emploi vous en avez fait aussi une de
vos priorités
vous affirmez je crois qu'il ya eu douze
mille formation supplémentaire est ce
que vous les avez évalué ce qu'elles
sont vraiment efficaces et ce qu'elles
vont bien au bon endroit
c'est ce que demande le medef notamment
il dit qu' il faut adapter vraiment les
formations le problème numéro un
au niveau économique c'est effectivement
peut-être celui là celui de
l'orientation
comment on fait en sorte pour que les
jeunes aillent dans les bonnes filières
les filières qui trouve absolument des
débouchés alors que nos entreprises qui
certes connaissent un taux de chômage
encore trop trop important mais en même
temps leur problème numéro un aux
entreprises aujourd'hui c'est de trouver
le personnel dont elles ont besoin donc
on a un taux de chômage inacceptable et
en même temps on a
entreprises qui ne trouve pas qu'il ya
un problème d'orientation c'est
fondamental donc nous faisons le maximum
dans cette région pour sensibiliser les
parents les jeunes au fait qu'il ya un
avenir dans les métiers de l'industrie
j'avais en franche-comté promu une
campagne publicitaire qui s'est traduite
sur les écrans de cinéma avec des jeunes
qui témoignent on va continuer avec le
recteur fallait deux recteurs avec le
rectorat je veux dire on travaille
vraiment sur cette question du lien
entre orientations et entreprises c'est
absolument centrale et puis il ya aussi
la question du développement de
l'apprentissage
nous sommes la région qui a le plus fort
taux de d'apprentis de toutes les
régions de france mais nous voulons
encore aller plus loin et je viens
d'apprendre entre noël et jour de l'an
que nous étions retenus comme région
expérimental pour aller au delà de l'âge
limite de l'apprentissage donc de 25 à
30 ans et je pense que c'est une mesure
qui est très attendu par les entreprises
parce que des jeunes de 25 à 30 ans ont
aussi une maturité une expérience qui
peut être intéressante pour tous ces
métiers qui sont en tension
sophie goy venir beaucoup de questions
nous parviennent sur les trains les ter
beaucoup d'inquiétudes chez les
internautes jean claude qui nous ni ne
supprimaient pas les trains dont nous
avons besoin mais jamais une inquiétude
de magali qui s'y trouvent qu'on
supprime trop de trains en ce moment
entre dijon et chalon sans prévenir les
gens qui sont abonnées semer les seuls
trains qui sont supprimés aujourd'hui
c'est en raison des travaux qui sont
faits et on n'a pas encore trouvé les
moyens de continuer à faire circuler des
trains
quand il ya des travaux sur les voies
des travaux importants donc les seuls
trains qui sont supprimés c'est pour ce
motif la alors après qu'il y a un défaut
d'information que les usagers ne soient
pas suffisamment au courant c'est
possible et à ce moment là je le
regrette là mais pourtant nous faisons
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup pression sur
la sncf pour que le maximum
d'informations soient donnés mais ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que nous sommes
en période négociations avec la sncf
pour une convention puisque nous avons
des conventions qui nous unissent
régulièrement avec la sncf et que nous
sommes en train de renégocier cette
convention avec un objectif majeur plus
de trains nous croyons en l'avenir du
dans cette région qui d'ailleurs même
sur la ligne des hirondelles question
kevin quel est l'avenir de cette ligne
la ligne des hirondelles c'est moi qui
les portait d'un contrat de plan il ya
deux ou trois ans alors que les
collectivités locales n'était pas
forcément complètement convaincu parce
qu'il ya besoin de travaux très
importants sur cette ligne cette ligne
ne doit pas fermer que petit à petit on
lui trouve une destination plus
touristique que celle qu'elle a
aujourd'hui avec un mode d'exploitation
différent c'est possible possible elle
ne fermera pas cette ligne c'est une
ligne qui est fondamental pour
l'attractivité de la région la reprenne
quitte à ce que je ne sais pas si c'est
là la région à vocation à la reprendre
mais on peut trouver un autre mode
d'exploitation à la faveur de
l'ouverture à la concurrence est là
aussi nous nous voulons être région
expérimental j'ai dit que nous étions
expérimentaux région expérimental sur
l'apprentissage jusqu'à 30 ans et nous
voulons être expérimentaux sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence qui
normalement est prévu pour 2023
mais nous faisons partie des quelques
régions qui sont volontaires pour qu'il
y ait un projet de loi qui permet de
démarrer cet appel à la concurrence dès
2019 c'est ce qu'a dit le premier
vice-président d'ailleurs dans le
reportage tout à l'heure michel leniaud
alors il ya un transfert aussi de
compétences sur les réseaux interurbains
de bus cette fois ci il ya eu des
accords signés entre la région et tous
les départements sauf la haute saône
vous pouvez nous dire pourquoi la
négociation est compliquée elle va finir
par aboutir sachant qu important c'est
de bien savoir que ces transports c'est
surtout le transport scolaire il ya du
pain transports scolaires
d'autre part les lignes interurbaines et
sur le transport scolaire
il ya une attente phénoménale des
familles et d'inquiétude de se dire mais
passant du département à la région
qu'est ce que ça va donner
j'ai même entendu la région elle sait
pas faire les départements savez très
bien faire et nous sommes dans une
discussion qui est constructive avec les
départements alors elle a commencé de
façon difficile parce qu'on a commencé
par discuter les bases financières donc
c'est toujours très sensible mais
maintenant nous avons trouvé des accords
entre départements et régions pour que
dans les six mois qui viennent puisque
c'est au mois de septembre prochain à la
rentrée que nous prendrons cette
compétence le service soit le
le mieux possible les familles dans
certains des facteurs c'est gratuit dans
d'autres salles l'époque vous à les
harmoniser tous à petit à petit nous
harmoniseront ce qu'il faut dire aux
familles c'est que dans un premier temps
là où elles sont ça ne changera rien
pour elle jusqu'en septembre
non mais à partir de septembre pour la
première année ça ne changera pas
stabilité et puis les agents qui
s'occupent des transports seront
toujours au même endroit ce qui veut
dire que les familles pourront continuer
à les contacter dans la proximité à ce
que ça souvent été un souci de dire oh
là là les agents qui connaissent les
problèmes auxquels on s'adresse
ils vont être à la région ça va être
compliqué non ils resteront là où ils
sont et puis petit à petit nous
prendrons les moyens d'améliorer le
service par le haut et partout de
l'yonne au territoire de belfort du jura
et la haute-saône donc mais les choses
se feront progressivement
sophie courageot procès survient dans
une pièce pions sur l'aéroport de dole
certains trouvent qu'il est en perte de
vitesse est ce qu'on ne risque pas
d'avoir un jour une région sans aéroport
écoutez cet aéroport sur l'aujourd'hui
questions d'alexandre sione sur des des
motifs de fans comment dire des
objectifs très touristique à c'est pas
l'aéroport de la région c'est un
aéroport qui permet surtout aux
côte-d'oriens et et aux habitants du
doubs d'aller dans des conditions
extrêmement intéressante passer des
vacances dans le sud maroc portugal etc
et moi j'ai toujours regretté pas votre
tasse de thé singer bref j'ai regretté
qu en sens inverse il n'y ait pas
effectivement des gens du sud ou d'une
heure mais pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de destination honneur qui viennent a
tout simplement dépenser leur argent
dans notre région parce que c'est quand
même ça le but du jeu le président du
conseil départemental du jura qui gère
cet aéroport c'est très bien que la
région est en train de prendre les
moyens de mettre à plat la question de
tous les aéroports sur la région parce
qu'il n'ya pas que des travaux même si
dole tavaux est un aéroport
effectivement très conséquent et dès le
mois de janvier là j'ai eu une réunion
avec toutes les parties prenantes de
tous ses aéroports pour les tenir très
au courant de l'audit que nous sommes en
train de
né qui sera terminé à la fin du semestre
et à partir duquel nous pourrons engager
un travail solide avec des fondements
solides avec notamment le département du
jura mais je le dis tout de suite pour
le département du jura
une représentante du département du jura
madame pélissard qui est vice présidente
au département du jura sera présent la
semaine par la semaine prochaine c'est à
la fin du mois à ce comité de suivi que
je mets en place
donc c'est pour dire que je mets en
place les conditions du dialogue
là aussi parce que sans dialogues on
n'arrive à rien et petit à petit les
choses se mettront en place mais qu'est
ce qu'on veut faire de ces hétéros port
on veut continuer à ce que les gens
aillent massivement vers le sud et que
personne ne vienne en poudre et le
franche comté on veut ouvrir des
destinations vers le nord
quelle fonction veut lui donner il faut
qu'on arrive à objectiver les choses à
trouver un modèle économique à quel prix
comment c'est pas des choses qui se
résorbent très facilement j'ai besoin
d'eux s'est tous dit pour avoir des
fondements solides pour discuter de
cette question on va continuer à suivre
ce dossier ce fut d'autres questions
pour une question de bernard deux
régions pauvres peuvent elles faire une
région riche et leur on se demander si
la bourgogne était pauvre et comment
elle pouvait faire et si la france
comptait était pauvre et comment il
pouvait faire
jamais cette question vous ne venez 1 et
donc moi je te suis persuadé que nous
avons des complémentarités très fort
nous avons sur le plan économique une
industrie nous sommes femmes faisant
partie des régions de france les plus
industrielles qui croient en leurs
industries je crois qu'aujourd'hui
l'économie très percuté par les
mutations technologiques les mutins ce
mur numérique mais en même temps
l'économie ne peut pas se développer
hors d'une base productive et or d'une
base industrielle cette base nous
l'avons et nous l'avons pour des
produits de qualité nous avons vocation
et moi c'est mon nom le jury continue à
perdre nous avons vocation et sinon de
mon ambition à ce que bourgogne franche
comté ça soit l'équivalent dans
plusieurs années en termes industriels
de la suisse ou de l'allemagne avec des
productions de haute valeur ajoutée que
ça soit dans les microtechniques
automobile dans la mécanique dans
l'énergie dans l'agroalimentaire nous
avons cette vocation là et donc nous
allons travailler à la faire vivre cette
vocation
il y à des emplois qui se perdent oui et
il y à des emplois qui se créent
regardez sur l'aéronautique a parce que
nous avons une position très forte en
matière aéronautique dans cette région
regardez sur le luxe regarder sur les
microtechniques regarder sur la santé
qui est un des fleurons de besançon et
de dijon les entreprises de la santé
iard a marché mondiales donc il faut
absolument tout faire pour faciliter
l'accès à ce marché mondial a les
directions une dernière fois les rues de
dijon et de besançon pour écouter les
citoyens de la région quel regard
personnel
ont-ils sur cette nouvelle région
bourgogne franche comté regardez vous
sentez-vous citoyens de bourgogne
franche comté
je me sens plus en bourgogne que
bourgogne franche comté comme ces
nouveaux noms ne sont pas du tout de la
bourgogne les gens je suis franco toi
que pure souche
alors je me sens beaucoup mieux
mais je me sens pas trop franc comtoise
je trouve que pour l'instant il n'y a
pas encore trop de liaison citoyenne
bourgogne franche comté jeu s'est passé
après j'aime bien la bourgogne je suis
fier d'être bourguignon mais voilà rien
de plus que ça bah ouais parce que c'est
bon je me sens bien ici et puis comment
la région est là pour nous et puis il
faut tout ce qu'il faut pour les jeunes
ouais moi je me sens je me sens citoyen
oui je me sens pleinement citoyens de
bourgogne franche comté
il fallait bien regroupée si ces régions
qui étaient vraiment trop petit moi ce
que j'aime bien c'est le pinard et le
bomber le bon fromage donc je pense que
ça va très bien ensemble
voilà alors marie-guite dufay
heureusement qu'il ya le val fromage
pour unir les bourguignons et
franc-comtois très important très
content
le tourisme aussi je pense que le
tourisme va être un facteur de lien
entre les deux ex région je pense aussi
profondément à la culture aux sports
manifestations sportives et c'est pour
cela que je fais un effort particulier
sur la culture et sur le sport le budget
de la culture va augmenter c'est assez
significatif pour moi c'est un facteur
de lien de partage d'union mais tout
cela prendra bien sûr du temps solide
questions sur la citoyenneté le
territoire de belfort question de rennes
1 qui se sont un petit peu délaissé en
disant vous ne vous occupez pas
suffisamment du territoire de belfort
vous avez favorisé deux ans aujourd'hui
nous favoriser dijon le petit territoire
se sont abandonnés
apparemment selon je ne sais pas c'est
une expression que vous venez de capter
parce que quand je vais dans le
territoire de belfort avec des
investissements conséquents que nous
sommes en train de mettre à la fois sur
la réouverture de lignes ferroviaires y
at il en france d'autres réouverture de
lignes ferroviaires l et belfort-delle
nous sommes en train de mettre d'un
financement considérable sur l'éco
campus pour l'université technologique
de belfort montbéliard et l'université
de bourgogne franche comté
belfort je n'ai pas le sentiment que
nous sommes à côté que nous tournons le
dos au territoire de belfort qui en plus
est le poumon industriel de cette région
industrielle
un mot sur le fameux logo est ce que
vous avez compris cette polémique ou est
ce que pour vous les gens enfin qui ont
critiqué ce nouveau logo de la région
bourgogne franche comté ont confondu
logo et blason écoutez je ne sais pas
j'ai un peu de mal avec cette ces
discussions ce logo pour moi je l' ai
voulu simple claire sobre avec un
objectif le trait d'union
il ya plusieurs traits d'union c'est le
trait d'union entre la bourgogne et la
franche comté il est sobre parce que ce
qui compte pour moi c'est vraiment le
faut le fond les sujets je le répète
l'emploi la transition énergétique une
société fraternelle bon alors après
effectivement le fait qu'ils aient pas
d'image mais je l' ai voulu qu'il n'y
ait pas d'image cité c'était pas
possible certains regrettent les deux
les drapeaux en laque meilleur palais
devant scénario de la zone aura je suis
en train de faire travailler les
sociétés chartistes les je vais les
rencontrer prochainement et il y à des
experts en matière d'histoire qui sont
en train de réfléchir à l'union des deux
blasons de bourgogne et de franche-comté
et et ça pourra être l'objet du trap
hausse et le drapeau du territoire c'est
pas le drapeau de l'institution du
conseil régional est bon donc il peut y
avoir cette confusion là mais ceux qui
souhaitent avoir le blason ils pourront
la voir
ils le garderont il nous reste une
minute l'avenir de la région il dépend
aussi de l'avenir de la france
il va y avoir les élections
présidentielles cette année vous ne vous
êtes pas encore prononcé en tant que
socialiste pour l'un ou l'autre des
candidats lors que la primaire c'est
dans quelques jours vous n'avez pas de
préférence je ne vous cache pas que la
situation est assez complexe et moi je
ne me
si tu pars en général en direction des
personnes en direction des projets pas
longtemps qu'on le connaît les
programmes des uns et des autres on
n'est pas d'ailleurs complètement
comment ils vont financer ses programmes
donc moi pour me prononcer publiquement
officiellement j'attends les débats je
pense que les débats seront déterminants
j'irais bien sûr voter à la primaire
malheur en espérant qu ensuite
l'intelligence prévaudra pour qu'il y
ait un rassemblement de la gauche la
gauche qui protège la gauche qui tient
compte de la complexité du monde dans
lequel nous sommes une gauche qui est
aussi qui s'inscrit profondément dans
l'europe et je pense sur cette
intelligence pour qu'il y ait un
rassemblement le plus large possible
merci marie-guite dufay nous avions déjà
ça passe très vite
au terme de ces démolitions merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci
aux téléspectateurs et aux internautes
et bonne année qui ont très bien à
l'aide à la grèce a envoyé beaucoup de
questions n'a pas pu pousser les
relations mais on vous permet rssi avoue
sophie courageux de les avoir quand même
relayé je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
voir ou revoir cette émission sur nos
sites internet dimanche champ politique
se poursuit après le flash régionales
bien sûr on revient largement sur cet
accident de car en saône et loire
bon dimanche à tous